lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
resolver varios ejemplos que nos
muestran que muchas de las propiedades
que hemos trabajado en la aritmética
como la propiedad distributiva la
propiedad asociativa y la propiedad
conmutativa se aplican de igual manera a
los números negativos y lo mejor es ver
cómo se aplican usando ejemplos
simplemente para asegurarnos de
comprender lo que sucede y como siempre
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolver cada problema por su
cuenta antes de ver la solución que
mostramos aquí
y todos estos ejercicios son del portal
de khan academy el primero dice cuáles
de las siguientes expresiones son
equivalentes a 1 por menos a por 4 bueno
quizás lo primero que se nos venga a la
mente es resolver esto decir bueno menos
a por 4 es menos 4 a x 1 y pues me queda
menos 4a pero lo que quiero que hagamos
aquí es aplicar nuestras propiedades y
ver si coinciden con esas opciones de
aquí recordamos que la multiplicación es
asociativa así que puedo tener esto de 1
por paréntesis menos a por 4 y también
puede tener por ejemplo 1 por menos
4 y tenerlo así asociarlo así 1 x menos
a por 4 incluso aquí podemos aislar esta
para que se note que es menos y no nos
confundamos con alguna resta o algo así
y esto es lo mismo esto es equivalente y
bueno vemos que tenemos 1 por menos a
justamente uno por menos a por cuatro
esta es una opción que aplica
y tenemos menos 4 a bueno si nosotros
hacemos la operación menos a por 4 es
menos a 4 por 1 pues nos queda esto y
también como la multiplicación es
distributiva si tenemos menos a 4 igual
puedo yo tener menos 4 por a es lo mismo
y aquí tenemos justamente esta opción
menos 4 a aquí así que estas dos
opciones aplican no elijo ninguna de las
anteriores porque tengo dos opciones
correctas veamos otro problema
cuáles de las siguientes expresiones son
equivalentes a menos a por b por b
veamos qué puedo hacer con esto tengo
menos a por b por b bueno una cosa que
puedo hacer es a lo mejor cambiar el
orden aplicar la propiedad distributiva
a lo mejor esta vez para diferenciarla
la voy a cambiar de color esta otra vez
de acá
también le cambio de color y puedo poner
por ejemplo be
no sé a lo mejor puedo poner por menos a
urbe o tener aquí
estévez pero ahora multiplicó cambió el
orden pongo acá estévez y al final pongo
el menos ar
bueno vemos que en esta configuración
aquí tenemos una opción de por ver x
menos a ésta coincide con esta opción
y qué pasa con esta será que ésta no
aplica pues si se aplica si yo imagino
que en lugar de tener esta menos a yo
tengo ve por ve por a
a su vez por -1 que es este signo
negativo pues yo puedo distribuir este
-1 en cualquiera de estos elementos
puedo multiplicarlo por esteve por
esteve o por el an como estaba antes que
que de menos a entonces nada me impide
tomar esto unirlo con esto por ejemplo y
tener
una menos ven por ve por a b x b por ar
y aquí está esta opción menos b por b
por a esta opción también me funciona
ambas son opciones correctas por lo
tanto esta última pues no le hago caso
veamos otro problema más cuáles de las
siguientes expresiones son equivalentes
a a x menos 10 + 11 bueno vamos a
trabajar en las posibles combinaciones
que podemos tener acá puedo aplicar la
propiedad distributiva y multiplicar
esta por este 10 y ésta por este 11 de
manera que me quedaría menos 10
si ponemos está por ejemplo de este
color menos si es por a más 11 por esta
misma a y qué es lo que nos dice acá
pues justamente tengo menos 10 x a este
de aquí más 11 a más 11 a esta es una
opción que aplica
la otra opción que me dicen es 11 a
menos 10 a pues aplicando la propiedad
conmutativa puedo yo cambiar el orden de
estos elementos este de aquí puedo
moverlos acá y tener 11
- 10 a qué es esto de aquí nada más
cambie su orden y me queda 11 a menos 10
a esta opción también es correcta
estas dos me sirven por lo que ninguna
de las anteriores no lo voy a elegir
dejamos un último problema cuáles de las
siguientes expresiones son equivalentes
a a por demás b elige todas las opciones
correctas pues vamos a hacer lo mismo
que hicimos en el ejercicio anterior
imaginemos entonces que yo tengo esta
que voy a multiplicar la por todo lo que
está dentro del paréntesis a por b y
está a la multiplicó por esta otra vez
si hago esto me va a quedar si ésta es
mi a aa por la vamos a poner este el
color a por b ya está otra vez vamos a
ponerle este color
esto me queda por ver estas dos más
que multiplica a esta otra vez
a problemas por b y esto es lo mismo son
la misma cantidad puedo sumar la de
hecho bueno aquí nos indican que se
suman además ve más a más b
va a ser igual a dos veces a b esto esto
y esto son exactamente lo mismo ahora si
vemos nuestras opciones tenemos a por ve
más a por b ésta de aquí que es correcta
esta opción me sirve y esta otra es dos
por a por b aquí también están dos por a
o por b así que esta opción también me
sirve